even though it's just five square
kilometers in size and
is the largest of the 36 islands which
make up the indian territory
of lakshwadeep until now the archipelago
was known for little more than its
untouched beauty
but locals say the indian government's
new laws threaten to end
every aspect of their way of life
our own land which is uh
given to us our by our parents
and that is now what the administrator
is saying
it is the government land and you are to
get a permission from the administrator
to
build a house
the directives allow the government to
take over land if it deems it necessary
for what it calls
development last month authorities
destroyed fishing shacks and boats in an
overnight operation
the bjp bharatiya jantha party of prime
minister narendra modi says it wants to
transform the islands into a tourist
destination
the airport is going to be expanded so
you will have
more tourists there is more income to
the islanders
every way islanders will be benefited by
these administrative actions
other proposed changes include a
preventative detention law
a ban on beef and allowing alcohol in a
territory where 96
of the population is muslim the people
of lakshwadeep say they weren't
consulted
my children and i don't want any big
developments or other things here
we just want to live our lives as we
have been we don't want anything else
can we get our peaceful life back on the
islands
as residents launched a campaign called
save lakshwadeep online
people in the indian state of kerala
have been protesting on their behalf
the territories share a language and
historic ties
catalase state assembly passed a
unanimous resolution accusing the bjp
of trying to impose its hindu
nationalist agenda
it's demanding the withdrawal of the
laws and the resignation
of the territories administrator
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi